nous accueillons nos gravité du samedi
20 heures ce soir yat-il swami bon score
alors là tu y soit ni depuis la mort de
clément méric est les groupuscules
d'extrême droite sont sous les feux de
l'actualité
de leur ultraviolence et la haine vous
les connaissez bien et pour cause dans
votre jeunesse de l'est était l'un des
skins des plus célèbres de paris depuis
vous avez découvert la spiritualité
hindouistes et de skins vous êtes devenu
moine vous nous raconterez votre
histoire à 20 heures
[Musique]
yat-il soit mire bonsoir vous êtes né le
16 juillet 1967 à levallois-perret sous
le nom de william de l'imi votre père
travaille à la ratp votre mère est femme
au foyer vous avez un frère et une soeur
plus âgée que vous toute la famille vit
dans une hlm de bagnolet dans l'est
parisien alors votre père est fortement
porté sur l'alcool vous dites parfois
quand il rentrait ma mère était obligé
de l'aider à enlever ses chaussures
il était très gentil avec ma mère en ce
moment là mais ils pouvaient plus d
habiller tellement qu'il était bourré
quoi j'ai grandi dans cette ambiance un
petit point lors tout ça vous semble
normal comme il vous semble normal de
mettre du vin dans l'eau à la place de
la grenadine vous dites l'alcoolisme
j'étais né dedans bah en fait il faut
comprendre que dans les cités gay vécu à
8 ans et la clope en
arrosant les premières cuites la drogue
c'est quelque chose qui est banal quoi
ouais à l'école vous découvrez une
aptitude à la bagarre et la célébrité
que ça vous apporte vous plaît en fait
un jour il y avait une terreur quoi et
donc j'ai répondu à ces affronts et
julie mines droite donc je suis devenu
un petit peu flatteur le héros coins du
monde a commencé à avoir peur de rien et
c'était pour moi nouveau alors en avant
vous mettez à boire de l'alcool à 11 ans
vous êtes accroché à l'alcool alors sur
le plan musique et look qui va avec vous
êtes d'abord rockabilly c'est à dire la
banane ensuite j'ai tarbes rock et si
d'ici ensuite punk mais c'est en 1980 à
l'occasion d'un voyage en angleterre que
vous voyez pour la première fois un
skinhead et une bird une belle c'est une
femme ce qu'il est quand j'ai vu ce skin
head là qui déambulait dans les rues du
marché avec cette femme elle avait des
cheveux roses les rythmes petite mèche
comme ça et là ça a été je sais pas
j'étais facile au point que je pouvais
plus les quitter des yeux quoi vous
dites je n'avais encore jamais vu de
look qui inspirait autant la peur je me
suis senti inspiré tout à fait alors
pour éviter la délinquance vos parents
vous inscrire dans un lycée privé rue
d'assas hélas c'est là que vous
rencontrez le tyran or le tyran vous dit
quand il marchait ils donnaient
l'impression qu'il était le contrôleur
du monde alors à partir de là vous
n'avez plus qu'une idée en tête devenir
skin faire partie du groupe le plus
craint alors vous couper les cheveux
très courts vous habiller comme eux à
commencer par l'accessoire indispensable
celui qui permet de basculer du côté des
méchants les rangers
j'ai trompé ma mère en lui demandant à
celui pour m acheter une paire de
rangers 1-1 bombers c'est en fait
c'était un look skinhead elle le savait
pas et à partir de ce jour là en fait et
j'ai commencé véritablement à vivre ce
personnage quoi j'étais prêt à tout pour
avoir une identité pour être respecté
pour être acceptée et et finalement vous
rencontrez la bande du tyran c'est des
skins de tolbiac et vous lui trouvez un
peu trop calme et finalement votre bande
ce seront les skins de gambetta et c'est
comme ça que vous rencontrez serge ayoub
alias batskin le fondateur des jeunesses
nationalistes révolutionnaires dont on
parle beaucoup en ce moment alors les
skins de gambetta fond de vous leur
mascotte et là vous trouver ce que vous
cherchez depuis toujours c'est-à-dire la
bagarre la provocation le rock'n'roll
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque ya beaucoup de
ce qu'ils n'ont pas rien les bandes de
skins fleurissent et puis c'est une
escalade de violence sans fin entre ces
bandes vous dites j'avais pris comme
arme de défense le vieux hachoir deux
buts par an quand vous êtes petit il
faut une arme je vais toujours une arme
sur moi car on venait malgré c'est quoi
mais attends piquante et skins tu prends
les autres ce qui n'est pas forcément en
fait tout c'est quand tu skin thème
personne tu as tout le monde pour que tu
crains tout le monde ça veut dire que tu
as tellement de haine tu as une parano
tu vois des ennemis dans toutes les
directions là vous devenez ultra violent
un jour il ya un skin de la bande des
halles qui veut votre bon beurre ou lui
exploser le nez à coups de tête et à
coups de poing quoi c'est vrai qu'à 16
ans vous êtes vraiment un adolescent
habité par la haine vous fait tatouer
des croix gammées vous devenez
complètement asocial et les profs
finalement s'arrange pour que vous ne
veniez plus en classe et professeurs
sont venus me trouver pour me dire
écoute on préfère que tu viennes pas en
cours on le dit à personne mais laisse
nous tranquilles en repart en voulait
traiter comme des ennemis pas de vue n'a
pu que votre banque vous vivez à
l'intérieur de cette bande de skins et
un jour vous retrouver en train de
vouloir faire rentrer à coups de pied la
tête d'un mec entre le trottoir et une
route voiture
juste parce que vous avez regardé fia
gt1
je demande pardon
comment dire à tous ces gens que j'ai
frappé aujourd'hui je commande je
demande sincèrement pardon mais c'est
vrai que j'ai fait des choses vraiment
horrible quoi ce que le plus terrible
c'est qu'ensuite vous ne vous enfuyez
pas vous jouer au flipper et la police
finit par vous arrêter parce que vous
êtes là quoi et vous prenez six mois
avec sursis donc voilà ça continue comme
ça une autre fois vous jouez à sauter
sur la tête d'un mec depuis le capot
d'une voiture en fait la violence
la haine à un moment ça prend un tel
degré qu'on en jouit et on prend plaisir
avec la c'est une drogue dure là c'est
une drogue dure et alors au lieu de
simplement frappé qu'un clin normalement
et bah vous imaginez des tas de choses
parce que ça devient sadique il faut
comprendre que dans un groupe comme ça
on boit beaucoup ça veut dire qu'on de
bois et après on frappe mais c'est une
chance que vous n'ayez jamais tué
personne en tout vingt ans et l'époque
où la bande commence à tisser des liens
avec l'extrême droite elle devient
ouvertement raciste et vous faites de la
musique à ce moment là au sein d'un
groupe qui s'appelle les evil skins est
votre chanson favorite s'appelle l'asic
l'on a remis donc seddik lancé le gaz
qui était utilisé à auschwitz la
politique c'est comme un à un décor un
fond j'aurais pu et de communisme il
reste qu'ils n'auraient pu être
n'importe quoi mais c'était la violence
et le gang qui est important mais
william vous saviez qu'il y avait eu
quand même des millions de gens dans les
chambres à gaz disons que j'étais devenu
un débile un débile mental j'étais
complètement détruit et un jour vous
êtes dans le métro il ya un maghrébin
qui vous demande s'il peut s'asseoir sur
un siège à côté de vous vous acceptez et
puis là en fait ils s'approchent à côté
de moi et puis je ressens je ressens de
la mort j'entends quelque chose et là il
me dit mais pourquoi tu t'habilles comme
ça pourquoi toutes ces choses si
haineuse et là je me lève et j'étais
complètement asphyxiés par la situation
et là je dis les jeudis mais je le ferai
mais je peux pas et là commençait à en
avoir marre de faire peur aux gens c'est
là que vous réalisez que vous terroriser
la famille juive qui habite en face de
chez vous que vous connaissez depuis
toujours et quand ils vous voient
arriver ils s'en vont ils vous prennent
pour un monstre j'étais comme un nazi
quoi vraiment là vous comprenez pas très
bien ce qui vous arrive vous sentez une
force positive venir vous chercher vous
ressentez vous le skin nazis un besoin
d'amour vous dit j'étais habillant
skinheads mais au fond de moi je
commençais à apprécier les gens je
n'arrivais plus à les regarder avec
violence je connaissais plus l'amour ce
cas c'est l'amour labonté et quand cette
chose allait rentrer en moi pour moi ça
a été comme un ennemi je me suis dit
tiens à un ennemi à combattre parce que
je passais ma vie à me battre contre mes
mots bonne qualité pour développer qu'un
boule de nerfs hélas quand c'est rentré
c'est quelque chose qui rentrait de plus
en plus je pouvais plus me battre contre
ça donc à un moment ça a commencé à
prendre le dessus sur moi et j'ai pris
et j'ai pris comment dire j'étais à
l'intérieur de ceux de ce look de ce
personnage et j'ai donné qu est ce que
je fais maintenant je n'arrivais plus à
l'assumer il a un de vos amis skins qui
s'appelle ce livre qui se posent aussi
des questions vous branchent sur des
livres de yoga de spiritualité de
méditation et vous découvrez une autre
réalité à ce moment là vous dites j'ai
ressenti une force m'envahir comme si
dieu n'avait répondu qu'il existait j'ai
touché par la grâce là j'ai commencé
véritablement à prier et à un jour il ya
quelque chose qui est venu et qui m'a
véritablement changé j'ai ressenti un
changement du jour au lendemain une
extrême quand on va au fond la haine
après on a envie d'aller au fond de la
noire c'est pendant cette période de
changement que vous rencontrez corinne
ou lui fait une petite fille vous partez
ensemble en guyane vous arrêtez de boire
de fumer de manger de la viande voulait
à ce qu'on l'a consacré votre vie à dieu
mais corinne ne partage pas votre quête
de spiritualité elle vous quitte en vous
écrivant que vous ne la reverrai jamais
que vous ne reverrez jamais votre fille
mais qu'elle lui parlera de vous le jour
de ses 18 ans et là vous réalisez que
vous aimez tellement corinne et votre
fille que nous vous ne voulez pas
d'autres voulaient pas d'autres femmes
voulaient pas d'autres filles et vous
décidé d'offrir votre vie à dieu et de
devenir moine
moines hindouiste ce qui explique votre
tenue en fait j'ai pas je les ai pas
délaisser pour quelqu'un d'autre si je
vais vers duathlon là je resterai fidèle
toute ma vie et j'aurais pas une autre
femme
et un autre offre mais vous n'avez
jamais eu de femme et gmail et autres
ont filmé
voilà vous partez en inde et au retour
d'inde vous fonder un monastère à côté
de rouen vous vivez aujourd'hui en fait
aujourd'hui
ma vie c'est un don pour les autres quoi
et
j'ai pu par la grâce de dieu et des
beaucoup de monde a changé
et beaucoup de gens ils travailleront
viennent me voir en fait
vous feriez des ce qui donnerait des
skinheads vient me voir si vous aviez
quelque chose aujourd'hui à dire aux
skins est justement à tous et ce qui n'a
vu leur diriez quoi
je dirai juste une chose
c'est que le problème il est dans le
coeur il n'est pas chez les autres même
si vous retirez tout ce qu'ils aiment
pas de la france ils auront toujours le
même problème le problème de tous les
êtres il est dans le coeur et on est
simple foncez pour aimer donc aller vers
la destruction ça résoudra aucun
problème ça le mot de la fin merci
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus